el 24 de febrero vladimir putin anunció
el inicio de lo que él calificó como una
operación militar especial para liberar
a los rusos parlantes de ucrania
tome la decisión de ejecutar una
operación militar especial y tambos
enfocaremos en la desmilitarización y
desnazificación de un grato estímulo
volodymyr celeste y presidente de
ucrania pasó de ser un comediante
convertido en presidente al líder de un
país que enfrentaba una invasión a gran
escala de aquellos que realmente luchan
por la libertad deben estar armados para
que el mal pierda y rusia busque la paz
son dos las tropas rusas entraron en la
región del donbass donde se ubican
donges y lugansk reconocidas como
repúblicas independientes por putin días
antes del inicio de la guerra en el
norte desde belarús tanques rusos
avanzaron con dirección a kiev el primer
día ya habían conquistado la antigua
planta nuclear de chernóbil en el sur
mariupol se convirtió en blanco de
ataques anfibios en el mar de azov
tres días de invasión y ucrania se veía
así kharkiv la segunda ciudad más grande
del país se convirtió en escenario de
constantes bombardeos
una semana invasión y rusia obtuvo su
primera gran conquista persona en marzo
las tropas rusas ocuparon la planta
nuclear más grande de europa sap orilla
mientras que el ataque a un hospital
materno-infantil el mariupol evidenció a
la comunidad internacional los horrores
de la guerra las imágenes satelitales de
un enorme convoy militar ruso hacían
temer una inminente caída de la capital
donde retumbaban las alarmas antiaéreas
el convoy represado por falta de
combustible y alimentos fue objetivo de
las emboscadas ucranianas
en abril el kremlin anunció un cambio de
estrategia para concentrar esfuerzos en
el donbass tras el retiro de las tropas
rusas del norte los cuerpos de civiles
encontrados en busca y voro dianca
fueron evidencia fehaciente de crímenes
de guerra que rusia se empeñó en negar
al tiempo la caída de mariupol parecía
inevitable
el 16 de mayo tras la evacuación de
cientos de civiles las fuerzas
ucranianas dieron por terminada su
misión en la planta de a soft al
mariupol quedó destruida y en manos de
rusia
el epicentro de la guerra se trasladó
entonces a severodonezk y tras la toma
lysychansk a principios de julio moscú
pasó a controlar la provincia de lugansk
y luego fue por lo que quedaba de donges
rusia amplió entonces sus ambiciones
territoriales
extendiendo las a las regiones de gerson
y sap orilla a seis meses del inicio de
la guerra el puerto de odessa resiste un
acuerdo logrado con la mediación de
turquía y la onu ha logrado desbloquear
las exportaciones de granos buscando
paliar una inminente crisis alimentaria
global
mientras ucrania planea contraataques
con la ayuda constante de eeuu y la
unión europea la planta nuclear más
grande de europa es el foco en las
preocupaciones internacionales
ataques constantes de los que rusia y
ucrania se culpan mutuamente hacen temer
un desastre a gran escala 1 que
producirse marcaría un punto de
inflexión con alcances impredecibles en
el que ya es el peor conflicto armado en
europa desde el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial